Peut-être savez-vous que Platon a qualifié
le corps de « tombeau ».
En grec, c’est un jeu de mots entre sôma,
le corps,
et sêma, le tombeau.
Alors, on comprend bien que l’expression
est péjorative
- ce qui est cohérent,
parce qu’un philosophe n’est pas un bodybuilder
qui voue un véritable culte au corps -
mais dans le détail,
parler de « tombeau » est énigmatique.
Pour résoudre cette énigme,
il faut voir comment Platon conçoit
les rapports de l’âme et du corps.
Vous allez voir que la question est loin d’être
subsidiaire,
parce qu’elle est en fait liée à la raison
d’être de la philosophie.
Je suis Romain,
et vous êtes sur 1000 idées de culture générale.
Alors, avant de rentrer dans le détail de
l’idée,
je vous donne quelques éléments pour préparer
le terrain.
Première chose à savoir :
Platon n’a pas théorisé les rapports de
l’âme et du corps dans un dialogue particulier,
c’est en fait une question qui traverse
son oeuvre.
On la retrouve notamment dans le Gorgias,
le Phédon, le Banquet,le Timée,
et à des degrés moindres, et sous d’autres
angles,
dans d’autres dialogues encore.
Donc c’était bien une question importante
pour Platon.
Deuxième chose :
comme vous le savez peut-être déjà,
dans les dialogues de Platon,
c’est généralement son maître, Socrate,
qui parle ;
et on peut donc soupçonner le disciple de
se servir de lui
pour diffuser ses propres thèses
- du coup on confond un peu leurs pensées
par commodité.
Ce qui veut dire qu'en pratique,
les idées que j’attribue à Platon dans
cette vidéo
peuvent avoir été exprimées par la bouche
de Socrate.
Enfin, troisième information préliminaire
:
la théorie platonicienne est DUALISTE,
c’est-à-dire qu’il distingue d’un côté
un monde matériel,
dont tous les éléments sont caractérisés
par des propriétés physiques,
et de l’autre côté un monde spirituel,
ou immatériel,
dont les éléments, comme la pensée,
échappent au champ de la physique.
Et c’est bien pour ça que le titre de la
vidéo,
c’est « l’âme et le corps selon Platon
»
- l’âme appartient au monde spirituel,
le corps au monde matériel.
Donc Platon, lui, est un tenant du dualisme,
position qui s’oppose au monisme
- du grec monos, qui veut dire seul, unique.
Le monisme, c’est quand on considère
que tout est réductible à un seul principe.
Bref, je ne rentre pas dans le détail des
variétés de monisme ou de dualisme
- Google est votre ami -
retenez seulement que la réflexion platonicienne
est dualiste.
Allez, on est prêt pour passer aux choses
sérieuses :
pourquoi qualifier le corps de « tombeau
» ?
C’est pas très sympa quand même.
Pour ne pas faire comme les journalistes
qui tronquent les déclarations des personnalités
publiques,
je vais d’abord vous lire la citation précise
de Platon,
tirée du Gorgias :
« Tu sais, en réalité, nous sommes morts.
Je l’ai déjà entendu dire par des hommes
qui s’y connaissent :
ils soutiennent qu’à présent nous sommes
morts,
que notre corps est un tombeau.
»
Ce que dit cette citation,
c’est que la vie dans le corps n’est pas
la vraie vie,
celle qui a du sens, de la valeur, et qui
mérite d’être vécue.
Vivre dans et par le corps,
c’est être mort,
parce que le corps pollue et freine la vie
de l’esprit.
Eh oui, Platon il est philosophe, pas bodybuilder,
donc forcément il survalorise la vie intellectuelle.
Sa théorie à lui, c’est plus précisément
que la finalité de la vie
c'est d’élever l’âme jusqu’à la vérité.
Vous le savez peut-être,
pour Platon, la vérité est située dans
un monde à part,
un monde spirituel, distinct du monde matériel,
le monde des Idées, qui sont les essences
de la réalité.
Or, on n'accède pas à ce monde des Idées
en prenant un ascenseur ;
non, il faut sérieusement s’exercer à
la philosophie,
il faut être concentré pour penser clairement,
et en profondeur.
Le corps est un obstacle évident à cet effort.
Les exigences du corps,
comme l’alimentation, la sécurité, le
confort matériel, le désir sexuel, etc.
empêchent l’individu de philosopher librement.
La santé est bien sûr une autre condition
nécessaire pour atteindre la vérité,
parce que la maladie nuit à la réflexion.
La vie sentimentale, également, qui est déterminée
par le corps,
perturbe la vie de l’esprit,
elle en accapare même une grande part.
Difficile d’accéder au monde des Idées
quand il y a Tinder !
Bref, le corps est pour Platon un obstacle
à l’épanouissement de l’âme,
ce qui est le véritable sens de l’existence
- c’est pour ça que vivre dans son corps,
c’est un peu comme vivre dans un tombeau.
Ce tombeau n’est toutefois pas éternel,
parce que comme le dit Socrate dans un moment
d'optimisme,
la mort nous en délivrera.
Ouf !
Mais est-ce qu’il faut pour autant mépriser
et négliger le corps ?
À considérer l’ensemble de l’oeuvre
de Platon,
les choses ne sont pas si simples que le suggère
le mot « tombeau ».
En fait, le corps n’est pas un mal en lui-même
;
il n’est pas un obstacle à supprimer par
l’ascèse philosophique,
ou en accueillant la mort à bras ouverts.
Le corps PEUT devenir un problème dans son
rapport à l’âme,
s’il sort de la sujétion à son égard,
ce qui est sa place naturelle.
En clair, il existe entre l’âme et le corps
une hiérarchie
qui doit être à tout prix préservée.
Ce n’est donc pas le corps en lui-même
qui empêche le philosophe d’accéder à
la vérité, au monde des Idées ;
c’est en fait une forme de désordre
DANS le corps
qui constitue une entrave à l’épanouissement
philosophique.
Or, pour Platon,
c’est à l’âme de préserver l’ordre
souhaitable dans le corps
- c’est en cela que l'âme est responsable
du corps.
Si elle ne tient pas son rôle,
c’est-à-dire si l’individu laisse son
corps à la démesure,
s’il se dissipe dans les plaisirs corporels,
alors effectivement son corps sera un « tombeau
».
Platon donne même des instructions plus précises
:
si l'âme veut que le corps la laisse philosopher
tranquillement,
il faut qu’elle veille à ce que l’ordre
du corps
corresponde à l’ordre de l’univers.
Cette adéquation nécessaire
entre l’ordre du corps et celui de l’univers,
elle signifie que le désordre dans le corps
menace par extension la réalité tout entière.
Platon écrit à ce propos :
« De toute façon, si l’âme n’était
pas là pour surveiller le corps, si le corps
était laissé à lui-même […] alors toutes
les réalités seraient confondues pêle-mêle
et reviendraient au même.
»
L’enjeu n’est donc pas mince :
il en va de la réalité tout entière.
Du coup, le philosophe ne doit pas négliger
le corps ;
au contraire, il doit s’astreindre à un
certain ascétisme corporel,
c’est-à-dire le soumettre à une certaine
rigueur,
afin d'éviter la démesure et d'y préserver
l’ordre.
C’est à cette condition que le corps peut
ne pas perturber l’âme
dans sa quête de la vérité.
À ce stade, la dépréciation du corps est
déjà plus nuancée,
par rapport à ce que suggère l'idée d'un
« tombeau » ;
mais vous allez voir que Platon est allé
encore plus loin.
En allant dans le détail,
la conception de l’âme et du corps de Platon
n’est pas aussi univoque
qu’un examen rapide pourrait le laisser
croire.
Alors, Platon est bien dualiste,
et il affirme bien la primauté de l’âme
sur le corps ;
mais leurs rapports sont plus complexes qu’il
n’y paraît ;
il y a des exceptions qui donnent au corps
un rôle insoupçonné,
une vertu philosophique.
En effet, le corps serait capable d’aider
l’âme à atteindre la vérité,
à pénétrer le monde des Idées.
L’idée plus globale, c’est que l’expérience
sensible
peut servir de tremplin pour la pensée.
Ce sont parfois des circonstances du monde
matériel
qui déclenchent la réflexion philosophique,
et il y a même des allers et retours entre
la pensée théorique
et le monde matériel, qui est le monde du
corps.
Platon admet plus généralement que l’homme
ne pense pas à partir de rien,
mais toujours, forcément,
depuis sa situation incarnée.
Il croyait bien en la réminiscence,
c’est-à-dire en l’idée que l’âme
aurait vécu dans le monde des Idées
avant d’intégrer un corps ;
mais se rappeler cette vie antérieure n’est
pas facile ni immédiat,
c’est un processus qui est déclenché par
des signes dans le monde matériel.
En clair, ce monde matériel donne paradoxalement
à l’âme
l’occasion de s’élever hors de lui,
vers le monde des Idées.
Ce qui veut dire que le corps lui-même est
aussi le moyen de la vérité.
Platon donne l’exemple de la beauté.
Pour lui, le sentiment si particulier qu’on
a quand on contemple une belle personne,
eh bien il est dû au fait que notre âme
se rappelle sa vie antérieure
dans le monde des Idées,
où elle a notamment côtoyé l’idée du
Beau.
Si la contemplation du beau corps est une
expérience forte,
c’est parce que l’idée du Beau était
particulièrement attirante
dans la vie antérieure de l’âme
- et donc son souvenir est très ancré en
nous.
À mon avis, c’est plus une histoire d’hormones
que de réincarnation,
mais bon…
Cette expérience de la contemplation du beau
corps,
c’est donc selon Platon un chemin vers l’idée
du Beau
- c’est plus précisément
la première étape de la contemplation du
beau en soi.
La beauté illustre ainsi la vertu philosophique
du corps :
il est capable, avec un peu d’entraînement,
d’initier à la contemplation des Idées.
Alors, pas mal pour un « tombeau », non
?
Que retenir de la conception platonicienne
des rapports de l’âme et du corps ?
Je pense qu’on peut synthétiser tout le
propos de Platon,
avec ses nuances insoupçonnées,
en disant que le corps est très généralement
surtout un risque,
mais qu’il peut aussi être un atout, avec
la pratique philosophique,
pour accéder au ciel des Idées.
Si on ne fait pas attention, si on ne maintient
pas un certain ordre du corps,
alors là, oui, il peut devenir un « tombeau
»,
au sens où il nous prive, par ses servitudes,
de la vie véritable qui est ailleurs
- la vie philosophique.
Mais si l’âme assume sa responsabilité
à l’égard du corps,
alors elle peut en faire un tremplin vers
le monde des Idées,
de la même manière dont l’expérience
de la beauté corporelle
nous ramène à l’idée du Beau.
Ce que dit Platon,
c’est donc que le corps est un « tombeau
» pour l’homme ordinaire,
celui qui ne sort jamais de la caverne,
qui se laisse abuser par l’illusion et dominer
par ses passions.
Le philosophe en quête de vérité, lui,
est capable de remettre le corps à sa place
dans sa relation à l’âme.
Ce qui est frappant, dans cette conception,
c’est que le corps est pensé par rapport
à la vérité
- par rapport à son statut épistémologique,
dirait-on plus techniquement.
Même si, on l’a vu, Platon ne dévalorise
pas tout ce qui est corporel,
ses idées sont tout de même assez révélatrices,
je trouve,
de la propension des philosophes,
à survaloriser, forcément, le champ intellectuel
par rapport au champ matériel.
Si vous avez aimé la vidéo,
mettez un pouce bleu
et abonnez-vous à la chaîne
pour être prévenu de la sortie de la suivante.
Pour lire ma synthèse de l’idée
sur le site 1000 idées de culture générale,
le lien est dans la description.
N’hésitez pas non plus à laisser des commentaires.
Pour recevoir les dernières idées de culture
générale
synthétisées dans le format le plus clair
possible,
vous pouvez vous inscrire à la newsletter
en laissant votre adresse e-mail sur le site.
Je suis Romain
et sous étiez sur 1000 idées de culture
générale.
Rappelez-vous vous n’avez pas besoin de
vous prendre la tête
pour vous intéresser au meilleur de la pensée.